all right well we are starting today
with hurricane Ian in Florida and uh
they they don't call it a disaster for
nothing this is not really a weather
show but there's been a lot of political
stuff revolving around the hurricane to
get everybody up to speed many trapped
in Florida as Ian heads towards South
Carolina reported by the Associated
Press
um there are rescue crews 2.5 million
Florida homes per the Associated Press
without power 2.7 million homes without
power according to other reports Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis told a news
conference we've never seen storm surge
of this magnitude it is basically a 500
year flooding event
when it comes to casualties hundreds are
feared dead now it takes a while to
officially get those numbers but we now
have heard from multiple political
leaders who are saying listen we're
being told about dozens if not hundreds
just in our municipality
so you start adding that up and unless
everybody's wrong you're talking about
at least hundreds dead
um The Daily Beast reporting that as
well as Millions more were plunged Into
Darkness in one of the most powerful
storms in American history and then uh
AFP and Yahoo news reporting floods
Devastation after Hurricane Ian hammers
Florida so there's a couple different
things I think that are important to
mention here for a show like ours first
of all we see a completely different Ron
DeSantis that I sort of knew existed in
the sense that I've told you all before
DeSantis is not a stupid guy his
incredible violent partisanship uh maybe
acute partisanship is is a better phrase
for it is a sort of a calculated
decision I'm not saying he's not a right
winger but he can get along with
everybody when he chooses to and he has
said Joe Biden's been good at helping
and everybody's getting along and this
is not the time for pettiness and it
again it's just another reminder that
it could be like this all the time if
people just wanted to be more reasonable
because that's all that's happening the
Santa is just being more reasonable in
part because he knows that his
re-election could potentially hinge on
is he seen as handling the hurricane
correctly in addition you know when
covet started many of us naively and
incorrectly thought this will bring the
country together we're all going to
unite against the virus and then we did
many Republicans essentially taking the
side of the virus ignoring all
suggestions and guidelines and
recommendations and not getting
vaccinated all that different stuff okay
fine with the hurricane we're just all
going to no
you've got people claiming that the
hurricane is a hoax now what does it
mean what does it mean that it's a hoax
some of them say well it was a rainstorm
but it wasn't really that bad and this
was just a way to get the hurricane in
the media
to avoid talking about
fill in the blank right whatever it is
this was a distraction some claiming
that it was a geode engineered weather
event of some kind again for whose
benefit it's like never really
completely clear others fixating on the
evacuation orders and are they legal or
not and mandatory and all these
different things folks it's a hurricane
okay oh and actually I should say some
also
immediately fixating on wanting to blame
climate change for this particular
hurricane and as we've talked about
before climate change is not really
about any particular hurricane but
climate change models would predict that
we would have more extreme events and
that the events themselves would be more
extreme but I I you know we don't need
to play the game of this particular
hurricane was caused by climate change
and
um uh uh uh human activities on the
planet we don't need to do that the
climate change models don't require that
so I think that that to the extent that
people on the left are doing it also
doesn't make sense the priority is
getting power back on
reducing fatalities as much as possible
um and starting to get things back
together and we will let you know how
things are looking by Monday
here's just a wild wild report from
vanity Fair's best Levin Donald Trump
thought he could sue Congress for
impeaching him he thought he could sue
Congress because as legislators they
impeached him now what's not clear is
whether he thought he could sue Congress
as an institution or that he could sue
the individual members who voted to
impeach and later in the Senate to
convict you know with Trump it's never
really clear what he means this entire
article is worth reading
um uh by best Levin and the key part is
actually from Maggie haberman's
forthcoming book confidence man which
says
uh when the house introduced articles of
impeachment against Trump for the first
time in 2019 Trump reacted with a
familiar refrain according to the book
I'll just Sue Congress they can't do
this to me best Levin adds it's not
clear whether Trump responded similarly
after the second impeachment articles
though there's probably a 50 chance that
he did listen this would not really be a
shock to anybody who's been following
the I guess we would call them trials
and tribulations of trump he thought
that pulling in a special Master after
the Mar-A-Lago search warrant was going
to be good for him and it did not work
out out that way
he looked directly into the Sun during
that Eclipse even though he was told not
to I mean like at the micro level and
the macro level he always believes
things that aren't true and believes
certain things would be good for him
that actually are not what's
particularly funny about Trump thinking
he can sue Congress is that right now we
talked about this yesterday on the bonus
show the argument that Trump's lawyers
are making to get a defamation suit
against Trump dismissed is that the
defendant should actually be the
government and not Trump and so you have
this extraordinary situation where on
the and and the point is you can't sue
the government for defamation so its
defamation versus the impeachment but on
the one hand in court Trump's lawyers
are arguing you can't go after the
government for defamation and really e
Gene Carroll's gripe is with the
government and not with Trump even
though it was Trump who said the things
that are allegedly defamatory and
meanwhile after and during the
impeachment Trump was saying well I'll
just sue the government as if that's
something you can do over a legislative
Duty that Congress has which is to
consider whether a president has done
something worthy of impeachment it's all
it it's all completely scrambled you all
know that and the other theme to this is
the things that are said publicly in the
court of public opinion by Trump and
even sometimes by his lawyers don't
translate to what they actually try to
argue in court these are two different
things and likewise nobody's going to
sue Congress for carrying out an
impeachment and of course it didn't
happen we will see what ultimately comes
of 2024 but best Levin sort of raising
the alarm here and saying listen
the election stuff was not the only
wacky dangerous unhinged stuff that
Donald Trump was thinking at that time
all right I have more to add for you on
the Quest for 1.5 million YouTube
subscribers we are dangerously close we
are now only looks like
3156 subscribers away
from 1.5 million and we have a bunch of
stuff on the calendar people have been
writing in saying David if you can get
to the 1.5 million sooner here's what
I'm willing to do and this is just for
fun okay everybody relax it's not like a
big deal people are just having a good
time all right if we get to the 1.5
million by October 4th at sundown I will
do the Yom Kippur fast I never do the
Yom Kippur fast I will do it and I will
live blog how bad it is to do the sunset
to Sunset fast for Yom Kippur okay if we
get to the 1.5 million by October 5th
I will obtain a unicycle and post a
video of me trying to ride a unicycle
down the street I've never done it this
was suggested by Anne from Utah and now
I have other things to add if we can get
to the 1.5 million by October 10th Bo
will get a bag of mangoes tattooed with
some kind of tagline from the show Bo
says his wife is a tattoo artist in New
York City and he already has a bunch of
tattoos and he's willing to get a mango
David Pacman show related tattoo if we
make it to 1.5 million subscribers by
October 10th October 12th Chris is a
muralist in Atlanta meaning that he
paints murals and he says if we get to
1.5 million by October 12th which is his
birthday he will paint a David pakman
show mural in Atlanta photograph it and
send it to us I think that that would be
absolutely awesome Kurt says that if we
get to the 1.5 million by October 21 he
will get a Mount Rushmore tattoo on his
back except it'll be Biden Obama Clinton
FDR and me which kind of scares me but
it sounds interesting and then Kelsey
says that if we make it by November 4th
which we really should
she will bake and decorate a custom uh
vegan David packman show cupcake and
send pictures and one will say Obama and
another will be Alex Jones or whatever
okay so she's going to do custom show
related cupcakes if we make it by
November 4th so two things one if you're
not subscribed Please Subscribe
youtube.com the davidpackman show the
earlier we get to the 1.5
the more of these hijinks that we will
be able to uh engage in and then
secondly if you have something to add to
the calendar like if you want to say you
know David if you make it by October 6th
I will
something you can email info
davidpackman.com all right one really
funny other thing related to YouTube
channels and then we're going to move on
to a bunch of other things you may or
may not know that we launched a second
really a third YouTube channel recently
and it is called Pacman Finance okay
this is not a political Channel this is
a channel in which we do personal
finance and a little light economics so
how to uh put together an asset
allocation why is some inflation good
why you shouldn't try to time the market
all these things
so funny initially when we launched the
channel a bunch of right Wingers were
like dude you're a socialist why are you
going to give Financial advice and some
of them have made a 180 and turned
around I love this this guy Tommy Boy
okay after we posted our first video he
wrote this is comical a complete
socialist talking about asset allocation
laughable hypocrisy now of course I'm
not a socialist but he was entitled to
his opinion the second video we posted
Tommy Boy shows up and he says dude
you're really gonna keep talking out of
both sides of your mouth on two channels
be a capitalist or be a socialist stop
trying to pretend you can be both now
having a budget doesn't exactly make you
one or the other but anyway Tommy Boy is
entitled to his opinion and then just
yesterday Tommy Boy shows up after like
our sixth video
and says Pac-Man gives sound
conservative Financial advice on this
channel ignore his utter nonsense
political advice on the other channel
and just watch this channel
tommyboy has been turned around 180
degrees by the sensible and sound
information remember I'm not giving any
individual Financial advice but the
information on the Pacman Finance
Channel I invite you to check it out
youtube.com
pacmanfinance we've got Clips going up
about all sorts of different topics and
if you have a finance topic you would
like me to address not politics folks
different Channel not politics you can
email info davidpackman.com and I will
do my very best to address that and soon
we'll be taking some personal finance
questions for the channel lots of
exciting things coming up all right we
have a fantastic show tonight it is Beto
versus Abbott debate for Texas governor
I will be live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook for that debate I hope you will
join me I don't know exactly what time
it is must be sometime around 7 P.M I
don't know
um and I hope to see everybody then
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is a viewer and
listener supported program it's the
audience that funds the work that we do
primarily through the bonus show and
full show made available through the
membership program oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad I welcome you and invite you with
peace and love to sign up at
joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code big
voting22 to get a discount off of the
cost of your membership let's go to the
phones you can call in on the Friday
show via Discord at davidpackman.com
slash Discord extremely extremely
important stuff to do why don't we go
first to Jason from Toronto Canada Jason
welcome what's on your mind today my
friend
hey David how are you I'm doing well
thank you
uh just actually go I have a couple
questions for you uh one politics
related
um
do you feel that as uh major news
networks are starting to distance
themselves from Trump and all the legal
issues he's currently in are we seeing
the slow demise of him potentially and
his movement or do you feel that that's
still a little bit away
um
as far as uh as seeing kind of the mag
movement kind of dwindled down I think
we've got a long way to go right now
it's not so much that the TV networks
like Fox News for example are stepping
away from Trump but they're giving
themselves other options in other words
they're starting to say hey a lot of
people seem to like DeSantis they're
kind of building the escape hatch so to
speak but they haven't yet pulled the
eject button if is if that makes sense
that's the analogy I would say however I
think depending on what happens in 20 in
November of 22 in the midterms and
depending on what happens in terms of
the indictments and public opinion
around Trump's indictments if indeed he
gets indicted then you may start to see
things change one interesting thing is
if you looked at predicted which is
betting markets DeSantis is now in the
lead as who is expected to get the 2024
Republican domination nomination based
on the betting numbers if those numbers
continue to go against Trump's favor you
might see an Excel acceleration but
right now nobody's really abandoned
Trump they're just giving themselves
other options
yeah that makes sense and just the other
question I have for you as a new father
what are you enjoying most about uh your
experience I I'd say like that you know
essentially day-to-day development and
just seeing how things change so much
from day to day and you know she's able
to do new things and attention span goes
up and ability to just like kind of hang
out without flipping out increases and
it really is I mean certainly from week
to week it gets very different
it's awesome good to hear all right
yeah things are they're good uh
temperature here is certain to drop as
fall comes in
um but otherwise things are all right
you could I mean I can't I I apologize
for this question but there's no way you
can get a good bagel in Toronto right
that's a Montreal thing
I mean you can get a good bagel in
Toronto you can it's less it's less
known but yeah there's a couple bagel
shops here in the city there pretty good
wow uh Montreal is known for it yeah
yeah there's some pretty good uh places
here and smoked salmon and everything's
available
yeah incredible for sure incredible wow
and you guys have the internet and
running water and everything oh yeah
yeah that's it's amazing we just got
cars a couple months ago very good all
right my friend thank you for the call
that was a joke by the way obviously we
we love Toronto thank you uh no no
offense to every that's those are just
jokes everybody relax all right let's go
to John from Kentucky John what's going
on
I can it it
sounds like you're underwater you're not
underwater are you
I'm not right oh boy you did you say
you're not underwater right now
I'm not underwriter right this moment
but now it sounds all it sounds so much
better what did you just change
I just went off of my car Bluetooth to
my handset beautifully done beautifully
done what's on your mind today
yeah I just had a I had a question
um I've been I'm an Uber driver and I
talk a lot of politics in the car which
is a mistake I gotta say yeah but um a
question that's kind of popping up as a
25 year old left this is just I just
what's the point in conservatism anymore
I I mean I'm not gonna I can't answer
that for you that's interesting so like
let me see if I can understand the
situation you drive Uber in Kentucky
and so are most of your passengers right
Wingers
well I I actually live in uh Louisville
Kentucky so we're a blue dot in a red
State okay so I get a good mix of people
so I'll have a lot of leftists in the
car I'll have a lot of liberals and then
a lot of the people that I get are
Republican yeah and I I just simply like
one of the things that I've been saying
recently
um I don't know if you've ever watched
Adventure Time no I don't even know what
it is
okay Adventure Time is an is a kids show
it was really really good though uh
there's this there was this uh vampire
lady named Marceline and in one of the
episodes she's fighting this other guy
who's the vampire King and they break
apart and the vampire King is like hey
Marceline you've lived over a thousand
years what have you learned and she says
something to the effect of
um you know everybody keeps making the
same mistakes over and over again and I
guess nobody lives long enough to see
the pattern right and well listen my
thought on that is as follows and I
don't want to interrupt the retelling of
Adventure Time episodes but here's my
thought there's two things going on with
conservatism one is the idea of let's
keep doing things the way we've done
them before just for the sake of
continuing to do them the same way we've
done them before which for me isn't a
very good argument necessarily right and
then also there is a sort of
contrarianism to conservatism when
people from typically from the left say
hey here's an advancement that we have
which will improve things there's like a
reflexive contrarianism where it's just
like no no no no no we're not going to
do that just because you want to we're
not going to do it so I think that those
are two important elements of it
hey 100 and like you know one of the
things I've been saying a lot in the car
is respectfully I don't have to have
lived a thousand years to see that the
story of human history has always been
conservatives or their historical
contemporaries fighting against progress
yeah and then leftists or their
historical contemporaries dragging them
Kicking and Screaming into that progress
correct so yeah I just don't see the
yeah it's just frustrating living in in
red state right now what can I say John
what's the wackiest Uber driving
situation you've experienced
oh
um uh honestly I've had too many bad red
I did have one lady get in the car with
the Maga hat and the flags and the the
pins and stuff and we're about two
minutes into the ride and she just
casually says you know I just can't
stand the way the media treats true
patriot right and so I kind of give it a
second and I'm like okay I'll bite who
are true Patriots and she says well Matt
Gates Alex Jones just to name a couple
yeah I'm like oh okay well I don't have
to say Alex Jones is full of crap you
know he says that in depositions and
stuff but uh Matt Gates the guy who's
currently under investigation from the
doj for child sex trafficking like this
is the guy who's a true patriot too
really have you ever had to kick anyone
out of the car
um I have not but I think that's mostly
because my demeanor in the car is very
much if you don't like it you can walk
so I think that more kind of like that
keeps people in line a lot of the time
so yeah well John I appreciate the call
uh stay safe out there
I'll try brother thank you all right uh
congratulations on the new child thank
you there's John from Kentucky with some
powerful powerful declarations as a
reminder if you want the uh opportunity
to get on to chat with me and you are
currently in the Discord waiting Lobby
your nickname must be name and where
you're calling from it doesn't even have
to be real like I don't know where you
really are but it has to be in that
format so people who just have like
single word nicknames and stuff like
that you're not going to get called on
just as a heads up so everybody knows
and is on the same page let's go to Alex
from Seattle Alex welcome
morning David
um I wanted to ask you about a book
written by a guest who had on a few
months ago Bobby azarian sure that was
called the romance of reality yeah
did you did you read the book I read
part of it yeah for that one I read uh
like I often do introduction table of
contents first chapter last chapter and
some stuff in between
okay interesting um I found it to be I
went up first off I wanted to thank you
for having that guest on and having that
book I I've in the process of reading it
and I've I'm reading it slowly because
um it's a very dense book I'm sure if
you read a couple of chapters you
probably like it's it's very um it's
explaining each piece as it goes
building its case for you know uh uh you
know why why why do we exist what is
life for
um I just wanted to know if you you if
in the brief parts that you read if
there was anything you found to be
um either disagreeable or if it change
anything about how you thought about
Concepts like Free Will determinism
because it goes into a lot of that
no I mean you know when I I read so much
that it's rare at this point that I read
something and it completely upends my
view it's just sort of like it now
averages in to My Views overall and just
like can slightly tweak things so I
don't know that I can say that there was
any kind of like big 180 that I did as a
result of the parts of the book that I
read but it certainly presented and so
did the interview you know you I I think
my view tends to be there is really no
one source that describes reality to as
far as I'm concerned what I'm looking
for are
thoughtful
ideas to integrate into my understanding
so no I can't say I had any real 180s
okay did you I mean is there something
you read in the book that made you say
wow yeah I mean prior to reading the
book I mean I um I really kind of
believed in the concept of determinism
it seemed to make the most sense to me
yeah you know ball rolling down a hill
add more complexity you know start to
finish I I feel like that kind of worked
and especially with like more
Progressive politics you can use that
lens and you can look at the way
people's lives exist and the problems
they ran into and you can use that and
the way the book presents it is kind of
you know it basically
takes things like life and it says
instead of it being a thing that just
kind of magically happened and it's like
a miracle it frames it as like it as an
inevitability based on fundamental laws
of Science and it continues to build
from there and so I found that it it
really made me rethink it made me
believe in free will again if that kind
of makes sense
um because it frames it as as uh you
know the concept of Free Will is the
ability to imagine uh possible realities
and then steer yourself there and um
anyway I just I I found it to be a
fascinating book I recommend it highly
that I as someone who does not consider
themselves religious
um I found it to be a thing that
explained the universe in a way that
kind of gave it a purpose that kind of
made sense so and I was just I was very
surprised at that because I'm highly
skeptical you know similar to your your
perspective around a lot of things I was
surprised at how much I connected with
the book and found it to be interesting
well I appreciate the feedback Alex
thank you I would love to have more
authors like that on your show we will
make it happen
all right all right so much Alex take
care very always great to hear that
people are getting value from uh from
the the guests on the show that's
fantastic let's go to Willie from Oregon
Willie welcome to the show what's on
your mind today
hey I was just curious if you have paid
any attention to the truth social ads
that it did popping up
no we just did a story earlier this week
about how the a company that was going
to invest 140 million to merge with
truth social they're they're just
completely bailing and Truth social is
likely going to fail soon but what where
are they running ads
uh well there was an update to the app
and so I did that and all of a sudden
notice that these ads started popping up
like that
it looks like Trump's the only one
paying for ads just anti-bitum okay uh
there's one for you know 2500 free
knives and reading through that was like
arm yourselves oh my goodness
it's pretty dark are you on when you're
on the app do you just look to see the
wacky stuff that gets posted are you on
there to kind of like argue with people
or to troll like what's your what do you
do on the app
oh uh could we cuss on this or no no
please don't okay
uh just messing with Trump and following
the the cuckoo there I see have you had
anybody like directly attack you because
of the things you post
oh yeah I did that for a little bit
um you know I there's not much Common
Sense on there so it's kind of pointless
to uh do anything but just like to keep
an eye on what that guy's uh
up to and talking and like you know last
night it looked like he he just reposts
the craziest stuff and uh it's pretty
scary yeah I like to kind of keep an eye
on them and see what he's up to but the
that you should look at some of the ads
that have been popping up on there
they're uh very strange I'll check that
out I'll check that out thanks for
bringing it to my attention
yeah yeah I think it's worth looking
into and talking about a little bit all
right Willie from Oregon very much
appreciate it thank you very very much
uh really really important stuff
happening on truth and it soon should
fail completely all right okay let's
take a very quick break if you're
holding to talk to me keep holding
because we're going right back to the
phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's
stick with the phones by which I mean
Discord davidpackman.com slash Discord
extraordinarily powerful phone calls
happening today and we don't want to
miss a minute of it let's go to Bobby
from Jersey Bobby from Jersey welcome
what's going on
Bobby from Jersey you got to unmute
yourself Michael oh David can you hear
me yes I can
all right is there a specific way that
you go about engaging with conspiracy
uh depends on the specifics I would say
I mean depend depends on where and with
whom
sort of like well I might say
um far-right conspiracy is like Q Anon
and like the election results and
whatnot yeah like is there really a way
you can like debunk that or I mean the
problem is that a lot of the people that
believe this stuff aren't actually open
to
thinking of
thinking critically about it and so if
you show them contradictory evidence
they say that evidence is not reliable
or has been planted if you show them the
absence of evidence for what they say
they go right because they're covering
up the evidence for what I believe so
unfortunately with a lot of them there's
really no way to talk them out of it or
even get them to reconsider
yeah that's what I've noticed too all
right David thank you all right thank
you very much there's Bobby from Jersey
yeah I mean unfortunately it's it's
depressing is the reality it's
depressing let's go to Rahman from
Minneapolis welcome back to the program
what's going on
thank you David how's your day going
today it's going well
yeah my first question is how would you
compare Donald Trump to past Republican
leaders like Richard Nixon Reagan Bush
and how and how they conducted business
in this country and their scandals well
I think that Trump has done
I mean listen compared to most of the
people you listed
all of them Trump has had way more
wrongdoing that he's engaged in than any
of them I think the difference is Trump
has had the benefits of the right wing
media machine including Fox News and
Newsmax and right-wing media and and
Defenders to the death on social media
and on and on and on but I think that
look at the list of all the things that
Donald Trump has done look at just look
at all the criminal investigations that
he's under right now so I think that
Trump is worse in terms of misdeeds I
think Trump's dumber than most of them I
mean Nixon was a horrible person but he
was quite smart
Reagan you know it was no genius but he
was he was relatively smart Bush was
kind of like when when it started with
the whole kind of dim thing but again
Bush seems like a Mensa member compared
to Trump so I I think that Trump is also
particularly just dumb in a very uh
superficial way
yeah like um what I believe is like like
if with Nixon he didn't have the right
wing media back then if he did I don't
think he would have been impeached
bright
I feel like with Donald Trump he's
essentially taken every he's just taking
every bad part of each of each of those
presidents like with Reagan he had the
Iran Contra scandal with Nixon was
watergating with bush it was uh it was
about lying about wmd's and and
torturing people yeah no absolutely and
I think your your spot on that had Nixon
had the benefit of this right-wing media
machine that was defending everything he
said all the time constantly it is quite
possible that public opinion among
Republicans would not have shifted
Republicans would not have gone to Nixon
and said listen if you don't resign
we're going to have to impeach you and
that that it could have actually saved
Nixon and so that the really scary thing
there is more about
Trump did enough horrible things that
were it not for were it not for the
right-wing media apparatus Trump might
have had to resign Trump in the 70s
might have had to resign and that really
puts a big Spotlight for the horrible
destructive nature of right-wing media
and we should not forget that
yeah uh second question second question
before I go this is very quick
um with with a lot of people a lot of
people going against progressives I'm
like progressives all they want to do is
make people's lives better like versus
Centrist versus right versus people in
the right wing uh progresses all the
other one do is make people's lives
better so why are so many people going
against them even though the the only
thing that they care about is making
everybody on the uh have a same equal
footing in this country yeah no I uh I
completely agree with your perspective
and the Counterpoint is the right would
say no no no listen
as the government what we want the
government doing is not making people
lives better it's letting people live
the life they want to live and if some
people don't want a better life then we
should allow them to do it it's a nanny
state that forces themselves upon you
that's the way that the right would
approach it yeah but when Republicans
talk about small government small
government in state of people's lives
yeah they're actually lying to people
with progressives of course they they
actually they actually want to stand up
people's lives and make people's lives
better that's all they really want to do
I agree with you I agree with you
completely but good luck convincing a
republican of that all right all right
Rock one from Minneapolis great to hear
from you again very much appreciate it
let's go to Alex from Baltimore Alex
welcome back to the program
hello hey David can you hear me yes I
can
all right uh real quick I wanted to say
congrats on the baby it's been a little
while how much has your espresso budget
uh increased since then you know it
really hasn't changed dramatically I
have to tell you because you know one of
the things this I hate to admit this but
uh with my particular espresso machine I
am much better at getting a double shot
just right than a single so often what I
do and I know it's wasteful but at the
end of the day it's just water even if I
only want a single shot I'm usually
making a double and then just dumping
the second shot that I don't want so all
that I've really been doing sometimes is
just having the second shot so it hasn't
really changed the budget
well lucky you yeah now white is that
surprising
um well just with with our child it was
a lot rough goings the first few months
with sleep so I definitely had lots of
red eyes and extra coffee and all that
stuff listen it's rough but it's like
how much coffee am I Really Gonna Have
you know
that's fair I was just playing around
all right I mean I guess a lot is the
answer who knows yeah fair enough uh
real question yeah so I had I had
something about um
uh eliminating the filibuster so I'm not
against it in principle or anything okay
but I but I do Wonder like and we just
got rid of it period like for example
Trump's first two years in office
wouldn't they have just been able to
just pass all sorts of crazy horrible
stuff and how would we stop that without
the filibuster and or is that just a
risk we have to take to get stuff done
now yeah unfortunately listen the
retrospective stuff I think is fine it's
like well listen if we only needed 51
instead of 60 on this then it might have
passed or whatever the problem is that
usually when people talk about that
you're going backwards only a very
narrow amount of time and also so what
you have to think about is imagine that
the filibuster had been previously done
away with and then think about all the
things Republicans would have been able
to pass when they had the opportunity
and also if Democrats did away with the
filibuster now think about what that
would mean for republicans and what
they're willing to do at some future
point so I think that's all fine I I
really do think the right way to think
about the filibuster is less about what
could we have done during this narrow
window but what might they do it should
just be listen
at its core
are there certain things where there
should be 60 votes in favor or should
everything just be 51. I actually think
we need to just be honest about how it
needs to be organized are there things
where we should have even more support
than that because they are so
significant and impactful to American
life I don't pretend to know the answer
but I think the best way to think about
this is less about we could have done
this if we had gotten rid of the
filibuster in January of 2020. I don't I
don't know I mean yes we can play that
game but it really is about does it make
sense that in this country you need a
simple majority or are there certain
things where you actually should have a
60 majority or even greater and to start
with that rather than just the politics
of it if that makes sense
and yeah no I get that I would just
personally I would say split the
difference and make it 55 that's just my
personal
take take it or leave it yeah I mean
listen it's it's some matter there's no
right answer it's like you could have
someone who says you know I think
anything that has to do with taxes
should have 57 votes and anything with
health health care should have 55 and
anything with budget should be you
everybody will have a different opinion
and I don't know that there's any right
or wrong necessarily but fundamentally
that's the philosophical question that
this is all about
right I just want to hear your take I
appreciate it all right Alex from
Baltimore thank you very much let's go
next to Jojo from California JoJo
welcome to the show what's on your mind
JoJo from California what's on your mind
JoJo from California your turn to speak
you're unmuted uh you're on you can
speak now
all right JoJo from California clearly
having
uh apparently some kind of technical
issues of various kinds Jojo I uh I'm
sorry that we are not going to be able
to speak but there is some kind of
technical problem half JoJo you're muted
yourself JoJo are you back now
no all right well JoJo's gone let's go
to Chris Chris welcome to the program
what's on your mind
Chris you're on the program what's going
on
so what you're live right now
for example that
Chris your life uh this is David welcome
oh yeah there we go
Chris you're on the air right now and we
can hear you go on my friend
oh I'm sorry I'm sitting here listening
I'm at work right now my guy yeah I'm
talking to you Chris
yeah I'm saying I'm at work right now I
can't talk I was just listening in yeah
all right okay Brook's going okay for
you
yeah yeah I apologize no no no I
apologize what kind of work do you do
um mandatory the beer distributor really
yeah what's going on with the Beer World
these days
it's hectic there's a lot of ipas coming
out is it is it just an IPA Fiasco these
days
yeah like right now I got a case in here
that's worth uh 120 the 24 beers oh my
goodness what country is that from
yeah
right outside of Philadelphia
sorry what was that Billy
I said How's my boy Jimmy from Philly
doing I have no idea
yeah you haven't been playing any of his
uh voicemails anymore we haven't been
getting any
wow
concerning well Chris listen a pleasure
having you on all right my friend
thank you my guy all right there is
Chris from Pennsylvania and I think we
gotta call it quits when we're ahead
folks so we are gonna do it for calls
for the week we will speak to more
people next week we'll take a quick
break and then get to your emails and
many more things quick break and back
after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into the Friday
mailbag anybody can be on the mailbag
you simply have to write into info
davidpackman.com we have a whole bunch
of different types of emails that we get
we get policy uh deep policy wonk type
emails we get superficial criticisms we
get praise and we also get trolling and
today we're going to start with just a
little bit of trolling it's always good
just to get a sense of the types of
things I get Peter Rhoden and Peter says
you're a political hack empty vessel are
you ever going to take that war
criminals phallus out of your mouth and
your is whyou apostrophe re
out of your mouth you pro-imperialist
Progressive boot licking peasant brain
loser no wonder you have a for-profit
opinion show not a new non-for-profit
newscast you don't do news You Preach
one-sided BS what's very interesting is
this is from a left Winger
this is left-wing hate mail they believe
I am an imperialist and not really a
progressive and that I just love Joe
Biden the supposed uh Imperial
imperialist war criminal and that the
fact that this is not a non-profit show
is part of the problem now what's funny
is he kind of agrees with Alex Jones in
a sense oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad yeah so
yes my show like basically every other
YouTube podcast show uh is not a
non-profit a lot of people might not
even realize to have a non-profit you
need a board you need I mean it's it's
actually quite complicated to be a
non-profit and it doesn't really make
sense for a whole bunch of different
reasons we considered it at one point
um these are folks who are in the you
can never be Progressive enough category
and that's why I flagged this one we get
a lot of right-wing hate mail but the
left-wing hate mail is also interesting
because in theory Peter is someone with
whom I probably agree 95 of the time
maybe even 98 of the time but this is
exactly the type of stuff that hurts the
left and you really hate to see it
but I can't control it it is what it is
Vincent wrote in Vincent now this is
right wing hate Vincent is a very
anti-Semitic
Vincent says Pac-Man why is the left
woke crowd so dominated by Jews without
Jew support the left would die on the
vine same is true for wokism only the
financial and intellectual support from
Jews allows wokism and leftism to
continue their evil existence why do
most Jews support such evil
yikes so remember you know a bunch of
different things
um Jewish Americans much like black
Americans are a very left-wing voting
block one of the most left-wing voting
blocs in the country
um when it comes to wokism as defined I
guess by Vincent
it's a relatively small part of what
there is on the left I think it's
extremely over represented in social
media and extremely overrepresented by
right-wing media but sometimes when they
say wokism you know I've talked about
where there can be excesses sometimes on
the left and I say sure I can talk about
this but these aren't like huge deals on
the left
sometimes what the right means by
wokeism is we're against treating people
terribly because of their identity
that's considered wokeism earlier in the
week we had this clip of this Republican
Mom saying I don't like all this Marxist
stuff like anti-bullying sometimes
that's what they mean they're just
really angry that it's not okay to
criticize people who don't look or sound
like you anymore so anyway uh pathetic
stuff anti-semitic stuff for sure but
very very common out there
um oh here's a nice uh nice voicemail
about my recent interview with Adam
Steen
my compliments I was quite impressed
with your interview of Adam Steen of
Wisconsin I really don't know how many
interviewers could keep such an even
Keel when faced with some of the
responses Adam had my compliments to you
sir yeah I get this question a lot like
in my personal life as well how do you
remain so cool with these people there's
two parts of it one is just the
experience of doing it
the second part sadly is a little bit of
desensitization when you've heard this
crazy stuff for a decade and a half
you do become somewhat desensitized to
the level of depravity
that is exhibited by many of these folks
and I don't know that that's a
particularly good thing because I'm sort
of suffering from a normalization in a
sense I'm still against the things they
say
but I'm used to hearing them when they
are very much not normal so something to
think about Ryan wrote in about
preventing life also the notion from the
Adam Steen interview
and Ryan says hey David the notion of
preventing life is completely absurd
you're possibly preventing life with
nearly every action you take for example
I didn't get my morning coffee today
because I was running late therefore I
didn't happen to run into my future wife
therefore we didn't go on to have
children thereby preventing a life any
action can be seen as preventing a life
thanks David Ryan from Milwaukee yeah
it's sort of like a um
it's like a chaos theory on right-wing
brain worms Adam Steen was saying not
only is he against
uh birth control I'm sorry not only is
he against abortion he's against birth
control as well because you're
preventing life
very very weird argument and it didn't
make it it see he even seemed confused
by it quite frankly Carl Rhoden Carl
says are you streaming any debates I'm
in Pittsburgh and would love to see you
do a stream of fetterman versus Oz or
Shapiro versus mastriano oh and a silly
name suggestion for the financial show
Pac-man the financial fact men okay yeah
so I have a whole bunch of different
streams that are scheduled when it comes
to debates
um tonight we've got Abbott versus Beto
next week we have JD Vance versus uh Tim
Ryan and then we have uh Mark Kelly
versus Blake Masters the week after that
we've got DeSantis versus Chris Whitmer
versus Tudor Dixon and if it happens the
Raphael Warnock versus Herschel Walker
debate although who the hell knows
whether any of those debates are going
to happen week after that we've got
Rubio versus Val demings if it gets
confirmed Oz versus fetterman and then
the week after that uh nothing scheduled
yet so there's there's actually close to
like a dozen different debates that I
plan on covering and I hope you'll join
me for those Dan wrote in David sir why
doesn't fetterman just take the Montreal
cognitive assessment exam I would love
to see Republicans make light of the
very exam Trump has been bragging about
for years yeah we had a voicemail caller
last week with a similar idea which was
basically Trump took a dementia stroke
brain injury test and brags about it
like it gets him into Mensa
if fetterman took it who fetterman had a
stroke and now there's people saying oh
we can't think whatever
um if fetterman took it and passed it
would Republicans then be satisfied and
the answer is of course not they would
all of a sudden say it's not sufficient
we it's
I I know that Hannity and Trump and
everybody brags about this test like
it's the be-all end-all of intelligence
and cognition but if it was what
fetterman said and by the way I got an
email from a neurologist in our audience
who said you know David it's not a what
if
almost certainly fetterman was given
that test that assessment because he had
a stroke and it's typical that that's
what you do it's not used for what Trump
used it for it's stunning stunning stuff
uh then a different Dan wrote in about
our YouTube thumbnails now this I want
to address in some serious some depth
Dan says those YouTube thumbnails that
involve a ridiculous facial expression
dude please don't do that anymore your
content is remarkable and consistent and
on point you don't need that cringy kind
of gimmickry much love Dan listen guys
they're just YouTube thumbnails okay I
get it there's things that there are
Trends on YouTube and other platforms
that are kind of gimmicky okay sometimes
they're even a little cringy but one of
the things we do is we adapt if we did
our titles today are dramatically
different than what they were a decade
ago okay the conventions and what does
well on our different platforms change
over time
titles have changed our set has changed
the audio equipment has changed how the
show is produced has changed and yes
thumbnails change and sometimes we test
thumbnails where I have a goofy look on
my face okay
if that alone
makes you not want to watch or listen to
the show anymore
then I'm sorry because really the
content is what I would hope would be
most important but we're rolling with
the changes if you don't adapt you die
in our space so listen if those funny
faces don't do well we'll stop using
them if they go out of style we'll stop
using them if they hurt us we'll stop
using them but we're just testing
different things that's all all right
please folks with peace and love Barney
wrote in about something that is really
really important
Barney wrote to me and said America is a
food desert
David Englishman traveling through the
USA here currently in Chicago
I speak to a lot of Europeans on my
travels and we are shocked that much of
the US is a food desert and that we are
all completely undernourished and cannot
follow a typically healthy diet we might
adhere to in Europe it's impossible to
find cheap healthy food literally
anywhere writes Barney
it costs seven dollars for a salad
thirteen dollars for a foot long Subway
for example I even found it's more
expensive to buy Florida oranges in
Florida than it is for me to get Spanish
oranges in England yes I understand
inflation is a factor but this is
happening everywhere and despite this
growth reason groceries and healthy
foods in particular are obscenely
expensive
I think the reason
is you have one National Supermarket so
there's no competition and there are a
general lack of supermarkets compared to
the UK so this part I don't know but
we have more than don't we have I mean
there's Trader Joe's there's Whole Foods
um
there's
well that's actually interesting is is
Wegmans National I'm not even sure maybe
Barney's on to something maybe we only
have like two national Supermarket
chains like I know Stop and Shop is just
a Northeast thing I believe
uh yeah that that may be a problem
listen Barney is completely correct and
a lot of people you know when I've
traveled through
the Midwest small towns in the Northeast
typically have great food and plenty of
supermarkets you know uh Upstate New
York and Vermont and you know Maine
these play there's typically no issue
but when I've been in like Wisconsin
when I've been in Northern Indiana when
I've been in um even Kansas City
Missouri it's like okay right in the
city but then it gets a little bit rough
it is a major problem and there's
multiple problems there's the the
pricing issue of course
the food desert issue where there are I
mean even even in New York and Boston
there are poorer neighborhoods with a
dearth of options other than chain
restaurants and there's also a lack of
Education sadly as to what constitutes a
healthy diet what does it mean to eat a
healthy diet well I don't know I eat I
eat chicken and vegetables but what do
you mean well yeah I mean it's wings
that I fried as well as you know mashed
potatoes exclusively right they're fries
whatever
there are definitely misunderstandings
about how a diet should be established
and honestly part of the problem is that
that old school food pyramid also was
somewhat inaccurate and confusing so
Barney you have correctly pointed out
that uh there's a lot of problems with
food here in the United States and it's
really like trying to you're kind of
like trying to dig yourself out
but as you do it you're digging another
hole
I don't know if it's the right metaphor
get your emails into me info
davidpackman.com tell me your stories of
food deserts probably worthy of a clip
coming up soon and we will see everybody
on today's bonus show which you can sign
up for at
joinpakman.com coupon code indict that's
the coupon code everybody knows why the
coupon code is currently in diet we need
some indictments the evidence is there
it's time see you on the bonus show or
otherwise back here on Monday